happy 30 birdy happy 30 happy 30th
birthday Abbey
okay so today we are walking from this
skirt once I got no screws this is gonna
be the littlest story ever happy 30th
birthday ABing okay so today we are
walking from the tippity-top of
Manhattan to the tubu do bottom of
Manhattan baby it's fashion baby it's
fluid baby I gotta fill it up right now
oh yeah dude I am so happy that you got
these a lot l'm on a shop up discount
$149 at 80% off okay and what sucking
only half a size smaller than the size
are actually where so work it down hold
on is that the key to my heart
yeah this is the key to your heart
what's the other one keep your ass
[Music]
you